great
so let me put it
the link for everyone
the youtube channel so that we can
continue so
thank you chris for the reminder yes now
it's recording
and we're also live on youtube so
welcome again
um so for tonight uh i
and camila will be our host and we'll
monitor the session
and so to give you more
info like some phase behind so pi data
berlin
uh is well that's one few of the numbers
that we have we have more but uh it's
always always very dynamic some of
participating for some time
then take a break and come back and so
those are just some of the members that
we have at the moment and also
humble also a very nice crew here
yeah so all of their work is
voluntary so please be thankful that's
really nice for them
and a really big thank to ibm who is
also sponsoring this event
uh so big big thank you and actually
also
being uh one of the speakers uh working
at the ibm
and well nice to give a really nice talk
about one of the tools stay open source
so thank you ibm for supporting us and
also
for the great content we have
and with that i think i'll give back to
tim
yes welcome everyone um
glad to be back uh at pi data hamburg i
think we had an event uh
before recently um glad to be with pi
data berlin
we left pi data we've been supporting
meetups
pretty much on a monthly basis since
last year um
and also going to be at the upcoming
conference so we look forward to that
so i'm just here to say a few quick
words about the ibm data science
community
we are 70 000 people some ibm's some
non-ibmers
uh there to share and learn together
about
all topics data science and ai machine
learning
so it's a it's a community of
practitioners
and learners uh and i hope you can find
the time to check it out
if you feel so inclined there's a couple
of offers we currently have
to kind of sweep the deal there is
access to a manning life project or
a complementary one month access to
select courses on coursera
so give it a look check it out and i
hope you have a great
event tonight thank you
yeah this is maria from the paidata
hamburg
and yeah you will know you know this is
a big fan to organize these events and
many others so this is a call for
participation
we are always looking for speakers
i am reading the slide you can do it
with me building something interesting
with open source data tools
speak about it especially under
representing groups and first time that
pi data speakers
we also help you we we try to mentor you
if you are not secure everyone is never
secure you know everyone is like
no i am not ready okay contact us we
will make it
we will make it together also we are
looking for volunteers
for planning the meetups like this one
today uh also to reach out more speakers
and to support in general
now it's online but in the future we
will need more support for
making the the meet the meetings in
person
and of course the sponsors as ibm is
sponsoring this meetup thank you so much
ibm
but also maybe your company or yourself
you want to sponsor a talk
and you will of course win some open
source karma
and yeah you may know i put now in the
chat
for the people in in youtube you can see
it here in the slide
there is this awesome conference by data
global
last year was so cool and i am sure the
new will be also cool
uh you is open they call for proposals
um
i am reading now again in october 28th
to 3rd
and 20th october to 30th october is when
it happens
and the call for proposal is open until
august the 15th
we invite all community members to
consider submitting first-time speakers
welcomed
and encouraged i must say that i have
been there
a couple of times and i promise you it's
the best conference ever
also because it's so inclusive so
diverse everyone is really welcome and
also big people like
i remember to listen to the anaconda um
how you saying not not developed the
head of anaconda i don't know like like
big people like
like champions of python like the big
people of red hat
and things like that like wow nice to
meet you
okay so there is the the link to buy by
data global
and i i think we'll explain now the
agenda for today
okay again hi so me again
so here we the agenda we have to do a
small modification so
actually uh usama will speak first uh
introducing elira and how extending
jupiter lab
for ai then our time also for some
questions
and we have a small break and then we'll
have the second uh speaker
uh jagadish mahindan i'm i'm sorry if i
say it right you're wrong your name are
we apologize for that
uh we'll talk about ar-based visual
assistant system
and then after the official then we'll
close after some question uh but you
will also be able to join for another
uh social event and wonder about me
um wonder it's kind of uh a small thing
where you can have a more uh
on on-site meetup experience where
basically you will be in a kind of 2d
map and you will be able to move around
and if you are near from someone else
then the camera will pop up and you can
have a chat about
whatever you want so recall we'll post
the link in the
in the chat at the end of the meeting
okay
we started you let's go for the first
talk
so i'm really pleased to introduce uh
gustano uh who will talk about
erira so luciano is an open source ai
platform architect uh with ibm codeite
and uh he will talk about area which is
an open source project
that he is uh currently developing and
where
it helps create ai pipeline and ex be
able to execute them locally or on
also external run types and so we'll
dive in with him
on every reference sonography and area
luciano
it's your turn
thank you thank you let me share my
screen here
and we can get started
hopefully you guys can see my screen and
uh before i start so i just wanna
uh i think we are cozy close uh set of
people here
uh usually when you when you're doing
this presentation it's kind of like an
in person
it's easier to feel how few people are
if they're understanding or not kind of
like in an online
scenario is a little bit more
complicated so uh
i really wanted to make sure you guys
get the best of it so if
he if you guys need me to spend a little
bit more time on
particular areas or have questions maybe
uh it's okay to
interrupt me we can have a kind of like
a
dialogue i think that might even make it
more uh
easier to to to get everybody awake and
and continue by the end
so uh again uh my name my name is
luciano hezenji
i work at the ibm code group uh
which is located uh most of us are
located in the bay area san francisco
um we kind of like
came from a group that that started
working on uh
what used to be called sdc spark
technology center
uh where we were doing a lot of things
on spark we started seeing a lot of like
uh
the scope of contributions kind of like
uh
uh going more towards ai and that's why
we renamed our
group to become coded stands for center
for open source data and ai technologies
uh anytime if you guys have questions
need to contact me
or wants to see what i'm doing feel free
to
i mean you have all the uh information
on how to reach me
feel free to contact me a little bit
about what we do at code day so
uh really our mission there
is to try to simplify how ai
is built and consumed
we have kind of like a separate groups
we have a
a set of like data scientists we have
and and we have folks that work
more on platform putting together all
these different
components that you use uh when you're
trying to build ai
and and data science and machine
learning models
and we we try to work directly with the
community all that what
all that what we all that we do is open
source and directly uh uh
with the community not uh sort of like
separate from from
the the ibm products inside of that that
gives us a lot more flexibility
uh we are really aligned
in in talking with the community getting
their requirements
uh and yes there is the the product side
that consumes all the things that we are
doing that that have
those in products but mostly with
separation we can
we can really make sure open source and
everything that we do
uh in that realm um
is very community driven
uh looking into a couple of areas that
we have been working on
uh and this is all components that we do
on our
our group i mean ibm has a
huge set of people doing open source so
this is really like what we do in codex
on areas that we focus on code day
so uh using ai we have
uh model asset exchange data asset
exchange those are components that
provides you very easy to use uh
data models that are already trained or
data uh
data sets that you can start just
plugging and play into
uh maybe a model that you're producing
or something that that
you can have a use of that uh the asset
exchange kind of like word here is
really like a just a
sort of like
a place where you can go you'll find a
list of like multiple models you can
then
see the source all vetted in terms of
like a
licensing and all those kind of stuff so
just really ready to use
uh we contribute to a lot of like the ai
frameworks we have
uh commuters at tensorflow pytorch
secret learn we are doing extensions for
pandas and contributing to panda so
all of those uh frameworks that you use
uh day-to-day we understand
um and
we see areas that can be enhanced we
work with the community we contribute
directly there
uh around kind of like a building ai so
like a lot of these things are
based on on the jupiter ecosystem which
is a project that is a part of non-focus
as well
so we contribute to pretty much all
parts of jupiter from lab
jupiter hub we created a jupiter
enterprise gateway
and more recently uh we created uh
lyra projects which we will be talking
much more in more details here
uh but dlyra is still not part of
uh jupiter we we are looking to what is
the next step in terms of like open
governance for going
into that direction uh we also
contribute to
the data and ai platforms which started
our group i mean
spark but here are things that we
contributed from from a long time cube
flow more recently
and we also doing a lot of things around
trusted ai uh
with the this components that actually
came
from ibm research and we
kind of like doing the bridge and
helping them making this uh
open source getting a community around
that today
those are components that are part of
the linux foundation uh so
all open source and available for
everyone to use and contribute for free
i'm going to really go
quickly around this unless someone asked
me to
go into more details but i'm assuming
that uh you guys
hear pi data uh a a
kind of like a meetup from new focus
everybody is familiar
with jupiter notebooks um
kind of like i just want to touch point
of like why uh
notebooks i think are very uh sort of
like a
use it and and welcomed into the
community i mean uh
we know it's like very simple uh but
very powerful you go to that url
you you get all what you need to start
developing there
uh i think one of the huge benefits is
the ability to be uh interactive so you
can
kind of like particularly when you're
trying to learn the data trying to learn
something
that you are trying to to maybe create a
model and stuff
i think that is a very important aspect
of it
also we know that when we're talking
with data scientists
a lot of them come from different areas
different backgrounds they might
prefer one language versus another one
script versus another
that is abstracted in terms of like
kernels you can install different
kernels which gives you support for
whatever you need in terms of what you
feel comfortable
so that is also very good in the context
of like a building
notebooks big data integration when you
need
spark and other things are right there
integrated with the
the kernel and when you're done and you
want to get some feedback or collaborate
with others you can share the notebook
more recently jupiter lab is sort of
like about to release the
rtc which is a real-time collaboration
all those kind of things it's gonna even
make it
uh the sharing and getting feedback even
uh
easier and more fun to do it so uh
keep looking to those you you will start
seeing much more
uh flexibility there on the upcoming
releases for dripter lab
uh as a result of all those benefits
when we look into market share
uh cryptolab jupiter notebooks kind of
like a huge difference from the second
place
in terms of like adoption uh and these
kind of like uh shows the the others
kind of like trying to compete there
but but uh no one get that gets close to
notebooks
uh in terms of like what we see on the
industry like cloud vendors uh uh
universities uh basically it's not like
oh this is a
an enterprise solution or this is is
everybody is using uh from from
enterprise to
to universities to kind of like
academics research
so uh uh uh it's proven to be there it's
proven to be adopted and
and it's the way to go for for doing uh
data science particularly if you're
really looking for
kind of like the ability and
capabilities of like
what the notebooks give you not only
code documentation everything but in one
place
uh jupiter lab i'm just going to quickly
go here jupiter lab is the new ui
kind of like a that is replacing or or
becoming more
fluent in terms of like what used to be
the one page notebook
jupiter lab gives you a lot more
flexibility and extensibility
providing you kind of like a more like
an ide
it gives you like abilities such as like
file explorer
widgets rich outputs console terminals
all
kind of like organize it into tabs and
uh you can have workspace
text editor and and and you name it
everything
is there and we do understand that
sometimes it might be too much
for for users uh recent release i think
the trio also have a very easy way to
uh switch back to i think uh it's called
simple mode
uh they rename it a few times already
but that gives you more like a one-page
type of like user experience
uh i think enough about a quick
introduction
let's take a look really of what is
elira and what lyra brings to you
so when when when we started
uh looking into lyra what we were kind
of like
helping some colleagues uh building
models and we started seeing a lot of
like gaps in terms of
uh i have this huge notebook how do i
split them into multiple areas
or multiple phases of the model
development life cycle
and then how do then i i can run those
together in different environments and
and all those kind of things that that
comes up when you look into that
and we started looking to uh uh
how can we enhance the jupiter lab how
we can uh make it easier for
uh uh doing all of this uh directly into
jupiter lab and make data science uh
kind of like day-to-day uh painful areas
uh even more easier to to build
so we created lyra uh initially we
created a few extensions and i'm gonna
just give a very quick high level here
and and
jump to a demo where we can see all of
this
uh working and uh but feel free to to
ask questions at any time
so uh the components that we
started the lyra with i think is ai
pipeline editor is one of the
uh kind of like a most popular one
initially we only give you the ability
to do like notebooks we started
expanding to
uh uh enable uh nodes to be also like
python scripts
r scripts where you can start combining
a more eterogeneous pipeline
uh we started supporting more runtimes
initially it was cube flow we then
started adding a local mode
but also airflow for folks that are
doing um
more sort of like uh analytics type of
workloads
we added the ability to to edit and
execute python files
uh in our files as well not only locally
but like if you need to
connect to a remote uh
set of like resources gpus that maybe
it's on the cloud available to you
as long as you have access you can
easily start pointing to that and
executing your code there
we also see that we usually have to go
back between notebooks or scripts
uh copy and paste like how do we plot a
graph or how do we
a function that help on on model
training uh
we decided to create some kind of like a
code snippets you can search you can tag
and you name it all of that really
trying to make your life
easier and make sure you focus on on
building your model building your
application
and and forgetting a little bit about uh
uh kind of like the devops tasks all the
the
underlying infrastructure pieces that
you might not be
all that familiar uh because maybe
you're coming from a
different background that is not a cs
background
uh we also have directly uh integration
with
git if you wanted to start collaborating
pushing that to get
uh checking with others and then
they can provide commands provide
updates
and you guys can collaborate on that
um we have a version 200 that
probably is about four to five months
old uh
we introduced it uh support for jupiter
lab 3.0 we sort of like
right after uh jupiter 3.0 got released
that we released the library that
supports that
uh with that a lot of things that uh
we were eagerly waiting for like support
for debugger
uh the simple interface mode which gives
you kind of like a a
one-page uh very undisturbing
ui i got introduced it we also
added into elira support for language
server protocols
that gives you an extra set of like
functionality more more towards like
what you see on ids
so ability to kind of like have a better
auto completion
you can then start kind of like a
refactoring rename your functions and
get those
propagated through where those functions
are being used uh
you can start jumping from definition so
uh
let me see this function where it's
defined let me make an update there and
all those kind of things
are directly in the notebook directly
into the support for python and support
for r that
lyra provides so like all the editors
have the integration with lsp
and and you can start using this
functionality on lyra 2.0
and we also uh introduce
uh support for different kind of like a
runtimes
on the uh kfb runtime that we
were supporting they they initially uh
kfp was supporting
argol as the platform for execution of
the the workflow
later on they also introduced support
for text on um
in in if you're doing using their kind
of like dsl
you have to code differently between
uh the the backend that you want to use
uh in lyra we made that a configuration
when you want to run you basically say
i'm using a runtime that is our goal i'm
using a runtime that is stacked on
everything else is is handled
transparent for you
so uh that gives you a lot of more
flexibility and independent
of like runtime details so
making your notebook or your pipeline
everything more portable
with allyra 3.0 uh which is a release
that should be coming up in the next
couple of weeks uh and i'm gonna be
showing all of the all the interface of
the ui all the capabilities
already gonna be uh based on alara 3.0
we bring you enhanced pipeline
editor we decoupled the editor so we
started being able to use that in
different ids
so jupter lab becomes one id now we we
have the
flexibility to support others we we
haven't decided yet but like
the idea is oh maybe you can start
opening this pipeline
uh in uh vs code as well or maybe you
can go to a different
place that supports your notebook a
different ide
and and start still being able to to
support your pipelines there
we also now have runtime specific
pipelines
uh that basically i mean what we
had in the past we're calling that a
generic pipeline
a the the difference between a generic
and
specific is that in a generic you can
run it locally
or you can say run on any of the
supported
supported runtimes and we will do all
the underlying
uh work to make sure your pipeline run
there
once you go to a pipeline that is
specific to a runtime
we then uh only give you sort of like uh
oh sorry we give you specific
functionality for that runtime
and then you start losing the genericity
of being able to to run in a new runtime
so that is kind of like
the difference but then if you really
know
that you're going to be using that in a
specific
like in a kubeflow pipeline uh
runtime you can use kubeflow components
that
you might already have be able to put
those into your pipeline
and and start basically just just
leveraging all that work that has been
done already in the past
um
i think i mentioned a little bit about
the the supported file so
uh when you're doing uh uh generic
pipelines you can
just drag and drop notebooks python
files and r script
all of that with support for
editing with support for
lsp and a lot of like the id
capabilities that is there
much more than than the basic jupyter
lab provides you
currently supported runtimes i mean
mention the local mode
which is available for generic pipelines
and then
the other specific runtimes that either
you can run if you have a generic
pipeline or a specific pipeline
so too much talk already uh
let me kind of like start driving to a
live demo
but let me pause for a second
and see if there are any questions or
anything that you guys might
me might want me to spend a little bit
more time there
oh no questions it seems that you guys
like it love it and already using that
so as i said uh everything that we do uh
is open source so we are located at
github.com
lyra that is uh the main repository
and you have kind of like a links to the
overall functionality uh
information on on how to try us and
everything
all available on the readme
we also have access to the documentation
which a lot of folks on the community
have been helping us to really maintain
that
and on the discussion side we also try
to put
kind of like a started pointers to
folks that wants to start
contributing or collaborating so if
you're just new
want to know about the lyra community
and and resources that are there
uh or if you want to contribute just
click on these links
uh now that i have
uh sort of like gave you a quick
introduction let me look into really
elira so once you join uh once you
you you start you have installed lyra
and you start
uh jupter lab you will see kind of like
a very familiar
user interface if you if you've been
using a jupiter lab
but you will see that you will have this
alara category
uh introduce it on the launcher and you
start seeing some of the
uh editors that we introduced uh you
also
gonna start seeing some things like a
runtime configuration
in in other things here so let me
start looking into pipelines
and we will drive from there
so if i want to just very easily start
creating a pipeline you can click here
you get an empty canvas
and you can start just dragging and drop
as easy as that files that are supported
you can start basically
connecting them in terms of like
dependencies
and if i can move this thing from my
ui you will see that we have node
properties as well the node properties
allows you to enter additional
information
for each of the nodes so i think one of
the things that we
identified is well i might have this
notebook that runs uh
python code but then i might have this
uh python script or maybe an r script
that requires
a different set of like uh dependencies
or or just in general a different
environment
so you can select a different runtime uh
images uh depending on for for each node
uh these are just docker images that are
gonna be used
and as kind of like the environment to
run that notebook
into into the runtime and we do
all the magic to giving that runtime
image
anything that is specific to a specific
requirement to run the notebook in
itself
we will add there and make sure it's
available there so like a
the notebook server as an example or or
any dependencies that is needed for that
one
similarly to python in our we make sure
that
additional dependencies or anything is
there in this case
uh but if i had for example uh
let me see here i think
i have some r so i if it was r then i
can say okay
for this one i want the r script oh
sorry
for this one i want the r uh image and
this one is
should be and i can still uh
do the links here you can specify
resources if you want to give
larger large amount of resource to to
specific place
all this one is doing the model training
or or or can
benefit of gpus you can come here and
set gpu
and if that is available uh we'll make
sure it gets allocated for you
uh a lot of times we are doing this
implementation
and we have uh local dependencies so
uh for example i want to add
uh those csvs and and have them
available
uh you can come and say okay star dot
csv
and and the runtime will make sure that
those dependencies are
properly packaged as well when you try
to execute
uh you can specify environment variables
yes i have a question from either
youtube
and uh is uh
sorry uh can ali arabic leverage for etl
workflow too
that's from major from
[Music]
your workflow can be doing atl
uh basically we don't have any
restriction of like
what type of things you're doing
so uh when you open the notebook it's
just
a regular notebook in this case i'm
processing and consuming some of the
input files
but if i look into the producer here
uh basically i'm doing some sort of like
atl and and reading a csv maybe a
playing with the output or in generating
some other file
so your notebook your python script what
the logic in there can be
just an etl if i look into another
example here
which is a little bit more complex but
can give you a more uh
real scenario use case this is a uh
what we call like a covid uh analytics
scenario
uh the initial notebooks are actually
going in
and looking to the data preparing the
data and cleaning the data
before it can actually be kind of like a
any analytics can be done on that so to
that extent
yeah it's just like the contents of the
notebook you you can model
the way it makes more sense for the
application that you're building it
and the data then
uh i you can pass it and
pass it to the the job or you can also
load it from s3 from whatever you are
probably some configuration to set up
yeah correct i i
i was going to talk about the uh the the
runtime
uh and and the cloud object storage like
s3
integration uh when i was about to run
that but let me give you
so uh we can have this notion of like a
runtimes
and runtimes when you configure a
runtime
you have basically two types of
information here
uh let's say you're using a kfp so a
keyflow pipeline
how do you access the pipeline but you
can also then say where the data that
i'm going to be using
uh is going to be located so that gives
you
uh the ability to basically say oh
there's going to be this
cloud object storage uh add dependencies
and everything that i need into that and
that is also gonna
what's gonna be use it so uh
when i go back uh to
my give me one second
i can't see here
okay when you go back to to a pipeline
uh you can especially let me
let me open a pipeline that it's already
all completed here um
so that is the scenario that i was
manually building with you guys
but you can start seeing that so all
setup ti
will uh require this file
um but then others will start
providing output files those output
files
are automatically propagated to
subsequent nodes
so if you're using that output file here
you will be able to just you will
receive those files from the previous
node
and this one then is creating more
output files that then
when you go to the consumer all of that
is available for them
and all of those the flow of the data
is being uh transferred
uh using the associated cloud object
storage
uh and you can access data from there as
well
uh uh programmatically uh if you have
additional or or
other information particularly like on
etl data yeah
cool thanks thank you thanks for the
question
and then um so when you're done
with building your pipeline so you have
all your nodes all your dependencies and
everything
all the properties uh and you want to
run that so we have this
run button uh it's pretty much
uh all you need um as i mentioned if you
have a generic pipeline you
have the ability to specify where you
want to run you can run just as a
a local uh uh which will use the
resources in this case of my laptop
or i can see uh please run on this uh
airflow or
kubeflow pipeline runtime
in that case uh usually is a a remote
runtime that you have available and will
give you
kind of like uh a access to additional
resources and everything
there so uh if i click here and i
basically try to run that
uh it does all the magic in this kind of
step of like packaging and submitting
so it will like if you have local
research
local dependencies anything that is
local it will package the way
it needs um data that is needed to be on
the object storage from from local
also we handle all of that and
you can then basically everything will
be started for you
we create a pipeline on kfb and we also
automatically start an experiment
so if i go here uh i'm then being
redirected to
a kfp uh server
ui where you can see the runs it will be
running
you then have access to logs and
everything
i've been running the demo uh prior to
this so i can see a couple of
other uh runs here and at the end
you will see all all the greens
you have the ability to look into the
logs if something went wrong
you also have all the details available
here
for you let me actually see the latest
one that is running
uh so yeah you you can see the logs
um you can see pod information if you if
you know
details about like uh the the runtime
that is running
and all of that but if you're just a
data scientist you just want to see the
results
you can basically look wait for the full
green
and then if you go to object storage
you will see
all the the details
that fingers uh and then
you can go uh and look into what you are
running
and um let me see just the name of the
and you will start seeing like all the
results here so like the notebook that
was run uh
you also have a version in html that you
can basically
download and open that file
or or look into the ipi1p
into actually doctor lab
and you can start sharing and
collaborating and doing that
uh so that is sort of like a a very
crash curse into pipelines
i got some some questions from this
channel
uh so if you are in local runtime if an
error occur in one of the node in a
pipeline can we restart it from the
point of failure
so uh that is an open issue uh
currently we do not support that yet
but it's something that uh after we
finish after we wrap up the trio release
we will
uh be able to do that uh so what what
you can do
in loco is to to basically you just have
the
the execution where it goes from the
beginning to to
end and i think in a more generic
way what we want to do and it's not only
if it fails for example
let's say this two is just data
processing and it's very heavy
um and nothing changes on the data you
know that so you just want to do
like from here up you can maybe coherent
and like you can do on the cell run from
this cell
forward you might be able we wanted to
enable you to do
execute from this cell forward i think
that's what we are thinking around that
but uh we haven't implemented that yet
uh if you really interested and want to
help get that implemented
uh we definitely want and and
uh welcome contributions so uh we can
definitely
uh really like work with you get you to
know uh
lyra otherwise uh we are looking
into that in the next maybe a few months
uh after after we finish uh the trio
release
great so something for me this
already if you want to join please enter
in contact with
luciano and he also had another question
and uh how can we access the logs in
local runtime
so uh good let me let me just make and
run here and
local uh everything that you're running
in local will go to
uh the jupiter lab console so if you go
and and see your your your console you
can see that the notebooks are being
executed
uh you you kind of like can see that the
percentage
while they are executing uh and
once it's done uh really if you just
open the the notebook for example this
will be the in place notebook that will
have all the updates here so the cells
it basically uses your runtime as if
you were going uh sort of like
one by one in the right order and and
hitting kind of like the the execute
all we sort of like programmatically
uh do the right ordering and execute on
your resource
uh using the research of your laptop uh
and everything in the context of jupiter
lab so
you can just go to the jupiter lab uh
log and see your logs
when it's in a remote then depending on
the runtime that you are using
uh that is going to be handling and and
taking care
of like how you can see or or any
details in terms of like uh
uh if something uh
went wrong retries all of that depends
on the capabilities of the
the runtime that is being used
all right thank you yeah cool okay
and uh how are we doing on time i i
think i'm
getting close to uh
the end of my time just want to double
check on that
we still have some time uh for you like
uh
ten minutes five ten minutes will be
great perfect
and uh so uh look into a couple of other
capabilities that we also introduced so
like
one of the things like when you go and
open a script you can see that you
have a script editor uh you can
uh just select and execute that python
script directly from
the editor in this case
you it will create kind of like a a
console in the
in the bottom here and you you will see
the results
uh if you have integration with
uh the other projects that we work very
well with them which is the jupiter
enterprise gateway
that gives you the ability to run things
even like remotely
so you can execute this python script
like
on a cloud or on a remote cluster using
more resources so even better there
you can then for example start
working on new notebooks and get
productivity uh
really up and running by leveraging uh
code snippets as i mentioned code
snippets gives you give you a list of
like
reusable snippets of code that you have
created in the past
uh let's say i want to do some plotting
uh let me filter what i have here
uh so oh this is uh give me
all the uh kind of like setup
i can uh easily drag and drop here so
it gets inserted in my notebook or it
gets inserted in my python script
uh oh and this gives me a kind of like a
sort of like a template for the graph
that i want to use
and then voila you can just click
execute
you have all the basic code that you
need you can start just focusing on what
is different on this particular case
and you don't have to figure out where
you had used this in the past or or
anything like that just
grab from your code snippets uh if you
don't remember you have the ability to
to search here as well you can define
different languages so uh let's say
you're doing things on a
c plus plus and you have some in this
case just a hello world
you can then drag and drop that into a
notebook that is using that
i mentioned uh the runtimes which is
basically a place where you can
configure
runtimes that you have access to we also
have what we call runtime images
these are basically uh
docker images that you can make it
available and use
as your environment to run the notebooks
or
or or scripts
when you are sort of like
building your pipeline and i think the
last thing that i missed it
and i wanted to we talked about the
runtime specific pipelines
uh which when you go uh
you will see available uh here so when
you click on a
runtime specific pipeline you will see
that now you have a different category
here
these are uh components that are
specific to kubeflow these are harvested
uh from a catalog that you you configure
like pointing to
the just the community and once you're
dragged here you then
you're have the ability to do uh the
node properties
which will depend on what what is
the the the specific component uh
requiring there but
gives you a lot more flexibility because
you can start reusing
uh actually components that are uh
maybe at your company or
or at your department you guys already
created a couple of things you guys
already using kubeflow where you guys
already using airflow you can just
started reusing those
um we got some questions
uh so from mithish can we save artifacts
of a pipeline run in local mode like as
in output of macbook in html pages
so when as i mentioned
for local mode
is just as if you were running uh
kind of like yourself so let's say
if i have this pipeline let me open a
notebook here
and let me do uh clear our
outputs so this notebook now
this notebook now has no outputs if i go
back
and try to to just run the pipeline in
local mode
it's just the in place notebook it's
going to be updated
if you went to that notebook and
actually
run it so let me just wait
for a minute here until that notebook is
processed
oh something went
let me take a look here but the idea is
when you come back to the notebook it's
gonna be updated
with uh the
the output that it's producing uh in
that case
if you don't actually have an output in
html
it will not create we create
automatically when we
we are running outside just because it's
easier for
for you to see because you don't have
access to that remote
notebook very i mean you have to
download the notebook first so
we don't have in the local mode the html
output for that
okay but you can generate it because
it's how the notebook is updated
if it's something that you feel as
a a very nice
feature to have uh i think uh feel free
to
to create an issue for us and describe
your scenario i think
uh we could probably uh easily have
some sort of like a tag here that says
produce html output in local mode or
some
some type of configuration that that we
can create that i don't think it's it's
hard to implement in the sense of like
code wise uh it's just that because you
had access to it locally
we we thought we didn't need that but
but
uh it's always good to get feedback when
we are wrong or when we
thought that something wasn't needed and
it's actually very good to have
cool uh another question also from the
the
youtube channel um is it different
is it possible to have different
pipelines file which could work at the
hierarchy of more complicated pipeline
so
aggregation of pipelines tap so
so yes and no
so we we have we have something
we have support i think you can select
multiple
uh and you can create supernode i think
that is
sort of like what you're alluding to
but i think uh
what the question really is is can the
supernode
be an external pipeline and i think that
is the
part that is not there uh
the actual canvas component
i think i just saw that they
uh they added the initial support for
that
in their release i think about like a
week or two ago
so uh it's definitely something that we
heard about and we got asked before but
we didn't have the support in the canvas
now that at least some portion is there
i think it's time for us to evaluate and
uh
really look into doing that but
uh yeah it's it's it's something that uh
we will have uh once all the pieces uh
uh required to get the support it's
there
cool thank you
and just wrapping up i mean uh
if you guys want to try uh we have a
couple of
uh different ways of trying i mean if
you guys are familiar
binder it's just a url that you can uh
launch and we'll give you all the uh
kind of like a hosted environment with
everything preset up for you
we also have uh ways of like just
running from docker so
a docker image that we publish with all
the releases
or you can just install a lyra directly
into your machine
uh some of the links uh uh
that i mentioned on the discussion on
like up getting started with
lyra lyra's github and everything uh
here
as i mentioned we are open source we
welcome
like new requirements or even
contributions
uh go into our github file issues
help with prs
talk to us we have a guitar
chat that we are there and every
thursday
9 00 a.m pacific time
we have what we call dev community
meetings basically
the developers get together we talk with
the community
we discuss and demo some of the
recent updates but also
if you guys have questions anything just
pop up there talk to us
uh usually we have all the the core
developers
uh there so uh even if it's
not my area of expertise i can redirect
you to somebody else
but and and you can definitely get your
answer there
uh and that's it i appreciate you guys
having me thank you very much
uh feel free to reach out to me if you
have other questions
uh we have a last one but i'm not coming
over school maybe you know
it's uh it's in the chat is uh from
lucas a really great tool
uh question is integrating with scale so
k-a-l-e something that makes sense
but i do are you familiar with scale
uh
i think i'm familiar with but it spells
different i'm not sure let me take a
look and respond on the chat
just to make sure i i get the right i
give the right answer
okay great okay thank you
cool so let's have a first break
so let's keep it for 10 minutes uh thank
you again this channel uh for the talk
was very interesting if you have any
other questions please
ask him directly or also we can also
meet maybe in the
uh in wonder
um yeah time to grab a beer uh someone
say in the chat
and see you in 10 minutes or you can
just stay around here
hi everyone we are slowly getting back
so i don't know if you want to unmute
yourself share a python joke
or just say i see people with the beer
christine is doing it absolutely right
i'm just here with my what but it's okay
it's okay it's okay
cheers
that's it hi jagashi how are you
hi i'm good thank you
just one thing how do i say your name
properly that i don't embarrass myself
oh that's pretty close
yeah sorry
[Music]
[Music]
yes it's yeah it's perfect
if we would have like more maybe one
hour let's do it if i make it wrong my
apologies it's on the best of my
intentions thank you
so much for being here with us once
again we are so excited to have you here
thanks for having me maybe we just
get started one moment let me just make
you co-host
sorry it's closed already
so i guess i should be able to share my
screen right
okay everyone so we are very my name is
camila
very happy to be here we moderate uh the
goddess
uh talks and he is going to
talk to us about aiv based visual
assistance system
and it's an obtrusive ai powered visual
a system system to help
visually impaired people navigate their
surroundings
by understanding environmental
conditions using deep learning on
edge ai devices
it's with you
let me share my screen
can you see my screen yes
thank you thanks for the introduction
pleasure to be here
uh today uh i'll be presenting on a
computer region based assistance system
for the visually impaired
using mobile edge ai and this is a paper
that was published
in one of the workshops in uh cbpr that
was earlier this year
and our agenda would be
discussing the common challenges uh the
visually impaired people face on daily
basis
and also what are the existing solutions
and
what is the general approach that is
followed in solving this uh
problem and
so take a look at what is the common
challenges
that is facing using the uh traditional
computer vision based solutions
and we'll eventually talk about our
solutions and our contribution
in solving
the visual assistance system problem
so visual impairment is is not a
small problem it's a global problem
there are around 285 million
people estimated to be having some kind
of visual impairment
according to the uh the global data
survey done by who in 2010 so this
number has increased already
um so among these 285 million
39 million are completely blind they
cannot see and 246 million
have low vision and cannot see complete
completely but they have some kind of
partial vision and
among them uh uh 80 82 percent of the
blind people
are more than 50 years of age
that is it is more common among older
people
uh however it is also seen among
english people as well um
so the common causes for visual
impairment uh are many
some of them are listed here one is uh
the
uncorrected refractive errors
contributes up to 43 percent
and there is uh
there's also cataract and retinitis
pigmentosa
and this is the most common for visual
impairment when it comes to
complete blindness it is a 55 percent
which is
cataract again and glaucoma and
age-related macular degeneration
and there is also a childhood blindness
and many other
issues biological issues here however
there has been some
increase in the public awareness of
these problems
and the affordability of high health
care services have increased
uh because of this there has been some
positive development
uh in this space which is a great news
but considering the population growth
rate of population growth
uh by 2030 it is estimated to reach 385
million
people which is significantly higher
than 2010
um so it's going to be you know upon
growing
as we move forward uh so which is
this is definitely a bigger problem to
take a look at
so some of the challenges that
that is uh faced by visually impaired
people are
they have a lot of density on others
even to do small things they have to
depend on others and
the unemployment rate among this
community is significantly high
they don't have jobs and i think it's
more than 60 percent
they cannot afford to buy expensive
devices things like that and
and also the involvement in daily
activities is significantly
reduced and even reading and writing is
a challenge for them
and also they uh experience of frequent
anxiety issues and taking transportation
services
walking through traffic and they also
encounter frequent ambulatory injuries
maybe uh you know walking into a tree
branch or running into an open cupboard
and so on and so forth
even handling medications are not easier
and using
ipad iphone or laptop for the matter
is also challenging for them
so there are a lot of existing solutions
there has been uh
some really cool applications and
progresses that has been made over
uh uh i guess like maybe even 1930s
uh the visual assistance system in
general they are referred as
electronic travel aids etas and they
mainly vary based on the type of sensors
that is used
in solving this problem and also the
type of data
and the kind of user interface that is
being used the user interface could be
uh
audio based through earphones or it
could be haptic
uh based
and it could also be some kind of
a vibratory motor that is being run
through the body to
show and transfer different kind of
environmental uh information the common
sensors include
you know cameras sonar gpus laser
infrared and so on and there is this
particularly interesting uh
application where they convert one
sensor data to other sensor data
especially here the image data is
converted to a
voice and using that sound the user can
detect where the obstacle is and maybe
even get
some kind of a sense how the
surroundings looks like
uh here are some cool existing solutions
uh
the first one is the tactile television
this is a big setup
uh the idea here is uh
the uh the image is translated uh
using vibrations on the skin so for
every image there is a corresponding
vibration that is run through the body
if you look at the uh chair here it has
vibrations
so each two dimensional information is
translated to the skin
through this vibrations the user can
detect like what is in the image
however with this setup the the
comfortness is is not that good
because uh it causes some physical
sensations and
and it's actually a physical uh
vibrations that is being transmitted to
the skin
uh after some time it might not be
comfortable you know comfortable enough
to
try this system but however this was a
very good uh
solution that caused a kind of a
breakthrough in this uh
setup and there is also this voice by
peter here
uh the idea here is capture the image
and convert it to voice
there is an interesting user who
actually takes interesting photographs
using the sound
and there is also been some recent
developments uh
the top one is lvs it is uh it consists
of a
laptop connected to haptic gloves and
also a stereo goggles
which reads uh zero zero camera data
and they can also extract dip and
whatever is being detected
uh is transmitted to the user via the
haptic clouds the close contains
vibratory motors depending on the kind
of detection that is being performed
the vibration pattern changes there is a
hamsa touch which is very
interesting application it's basically a
replication of this application
but ported onto mobile mobile devices
here uh in the image basically the user
as
uh as a as a as a strip that is
that is kind of attached to the backside
of the phone whatever image that is
being collected from the camera
the vibration is transmitted uh through
this uh vibratory motor on the strip
very similar to the first setup but it
is compact
and there are also various other
applications
for example microsoft seeing ai this
application
is from microsoft which can detect
objects
and provide what is being seen
uh to the user as audio commands
and there is also tap tap c similar
application
uh lasso's app is another application
which is
purely gps based helps in navigating the
user from one point to other
so these are some interesting
application existing applications
uh so uh let's take a look at
what are the common challenges faced in
uh existing solutions right
so with gps they are not very accurate
especially if it is indoor
or urban areas the accuracy is
significantly
reduced they are not reliable in such
settings and
sonars have poor directional resolutions
and they are kind of susceptible to
noise
and cameras is is is pretty interesting
and uh considering the latest uh
progress that has been happening in
computer vision
we are able to achieve so many things in
computer operation um
however the challenge here will be like
how to make sure the
the developed computer vision algorithms
are robust
in real world settings the algorithms
sometimes perform really well
within the indoor settings but if you
apply the same algorithm
in the real world outside it might or
might not perform as expected
and user interface haptics is
a might not be comfortable always
and with earphones we are blocking the
audio cues that is that the user
receives especially
people who are visually impaired they
rely highly on
audio queues when we're using earphones
uh the audio information might be
blocked
these are some common common challenges
faced in the existing solutions
uh we will be focusing more on the
computer vision based approaches
and uh we'll talk about like what is
where we make our impact
so the common challenges in computer
vision is
you know uh uh deep learning is new uh
technologies and the existing solutions
you know use
the traditional computer vision
techniques uh which
uh are not robust in real world settings
like i explained earlier maybe they can
work well within a particular setting
inside a house
or inside a room or with a particular
light setting and so on and so forth
so generalizing this solution is
extremely hard once you step out the
house
you might not guarantee the performance
of this system because
you know the problems like object
detections or semantic segmentation is
extremely hard to solve
using uh traditional computer vision
techniques and also they are you know
very sensitive to noise
which make them a kind of less reliable
which is why in our solution we are
using deep learning based methods
which uses you know machine learning and
artificial intelligence techniques
using object detection semantic
segmentation and image classification
techniques
they are they are much reliable than
computer vision techniques uh however
the challenges with deep learning would
be they're computationally intensive
you need a specialized hardware like
gpus or aji devices
the traditional deep learning based
methods they kind of use
you know heavy gpus especially if you
look at uh self-driving cars
they have like you know many gpus that
are stacked on top of each other
so imagine carrying a backpack with full
of gpus
and fans and in a power supply that
won't be
a nice user experience for this
applications
so in our solution we have tried to
overcome all these challenges
by using agi devices
that enables deep learning these are
kind of the sub components that have
used in our approach
uh we've used ogde sensor from luxonis
this provides stereo camera images
uh using two cameras it can provide the
depth information as well
apart from that it also has an embedded
ai chip
uh the the benefit of having this is
the chip can actually process the
collected image data
before even the data is being sent to
the host mission
so kind of a partial processing is done
already on the chip
before it even reaches the host
and we also use hi devices such as
neural compute sticks
the all the deep learning models that we
train are optimized
to fit into small hardwares such as in a
neural compute sticks which looks like a
usb stick
it can be plugged to a laptop and we can
run a model on that and we're using a
gps uh usb enabled gps to track
the user locations and for audio
for the user interface we're using audio
especially the bluetooth enabled
earphones
and one of the main benefits of this
system is
it's wearable and it's also unobtrusive
the the the unoperativeness is
extremely critical factor we conducted a
lot of surveys
uh before we kind of you know fixed on a
design
and in this service we found that uh one
of the challenges they face is that
you know while they're walking in the
street they get a lot of
unnecessary attention by other
pedestrians in the public places
and that's something that we wanted to
address and
we wanted to make our system completely
unobtrusive
and which is why we wanted to resort to
you know smaller hardwares
such as small cameras and you know hdi
devices which are compact and can be put
in a very simple form factor
and uh and based on the survey we also
found the common challenges generally
are
you know detecting moving objects and
especially walking in a sidewalk
when there is a dynamic surroundings
it's it's hard to predict and it kind of
creates anxiety for them
and also elevation changes can be built
especially if they fall down it can
cause severe injuries to the bodies
and hanging objects these are very
tricky
scenarios where the obstacle is actually
is in the air
and they don't have any base generally
they use you know canes in navigations
uh if these bass is there
you can detect that using the canes but
if it's hanging
you cannot use the canes to detect and
uh
upon like misdetecting these things the
user will collide with the obstacle and
it might cause damages to the upper body
sometimes even faces and apart from that
we are also using deep learning to
detect road signs and also traffic
conditions we'll be covering most a lot
of this as we move along
so our contribution mainly would be you
know we
would be introducing deep learning and
not rely on computer
traditional computer vision as deep
learning is more robust
uh and also we'll be introducing how to
compress this
deep learning use deep learning models
to a small
form factor and also keep the costs less
because the unemployment rate among the
community is extremely high
they cannot afford to buy if the
solution is expensive
um and also we are also performing uh
point load processing to detect
obstacles and also even pretty you know
estimate the size and shape of the
obstacles
read traffic conditions and detect
elevation changes
and also be able to share the gps
locations
with preferred contacts in case of
emergencies so these are some
unique contributions that is coming from
our projects that the existing solutions
cannot do
and all the solution is open source and
the code is available online
uh so this is the physical uh setup
it consists of a camera uh that is
concealed behind the vest it's an ob
camera
and and the vest has basically some tiny
holes
for the camera sensors to be you know
visible outside
and the camera is further connected uh
to the laptop that is placed in the
backpack and
the laptop is further connected to
multiple neural compute sticks for ai
processing
for running object detection models and
semantic segmentation models
and apart from that we also have a usb
enabled gps unit that is connected
outside the back facing up uh to
keep track of the gps coordinates so
this is the overall uh
physical setup as you can see this is
the setup is not very obvious
and i was able to walk in the street
without getting any you know special
attention
so this is our overall physical setup
and
this software uh setup consists of four
main components one is the primitive
perception
primitive perception mainly
works by detecting the presence of
obstacles
it cannot detect what that obstacle is
but it can detect if there is an
obstacle or not
this is an extremely important component
because this works on
point loads using depth images so
sometimes
the advanced perception which i'll get
into later the object detection might
fail in those scenarios
we can detect the presence of obstacle
which is good enough for the user to
make decisions on where to move
so this is purely using point clouds to
detect
just whether there is an obstacle or not
and this is being run on cpu
and advanced perception is is what is
uses
uh you know deep learning models heavily
that is
it can detect objects and also it can
detect road pixels and
road markings
and you know traffic signs so on and so
forth and it can also
fit uh the cuboid to
the point load that is being detected uh
so it is computationally very intensive
it needs special hardware
which is why you we use a neural compute
stick
and and we are also using the chip on
the od
and we are also using the host cpu
machine
apart from perception we have a
localizer right now the localizer
completely uses gps coordinates to
localize the user
based on the longitude and latitude
values
and for voice for user interface via
voice recognition system
the user can actually interact with the
system asking for certain features
like the features could be to describe
the environment
or to save particular locations we'll
discuss about that as we move forward
and in case of emergencies they can also
share the gps coordinates the preferred
contacts
via sms
so this is a primitive perception in
this use case we present a scenario
where the system can detect thin
obstacles like
wire right the image on the left
we show the wire the presence of the
wire that's the rgb image
the center image is the depth image and
in the depth image we can see this
quadrants that are marked with x marks
these are
the locations where there are obstacles
so so basically the primitive perception
will detect
if there are any points within the
proximity of the
user if there is any points it will
update
the user uh by saying uh there is an
obstacle in the front
there is an obstacle in the in the left
and so on and so forth
and and this uh detection is can be
set to a particular proximity within the
user it can be one mirror or two meter
right now i think it's less than one
meter in our setting but it can be
changed to different values
so here the importance is it will just
say there is an obstacle
however the same data is being processed
in advanced perception where
cuboid is fitted to know
what is the shape of the obstacle and
how long it is
or how wide it is to get an idea of
what kind of obstacle it is so this is
primitive perception
in advanced perception like we discussed
earlier we'll be talking about
you know detecting uh traffic signs uh
you know people
and uh traffic lights and uh
and also some road signs uh and this is
all done by an advanced perception
the same perception model can also
detect road pixels
from road markings and right now we can
detect a bunch of things
this includes people's people car
traffic lights
traffic signs even fire hydrant and we
can also extract the crosswalk
markings from the road can detect the
sidewalks
from the curb so this is a pretty
involved process for which we had to
collect a lot of data set
some of them are custom data set that is
that was collected by walking along the
neighborhood streets in monrovia city
in california and we also utilized some
standard data set that was available
online uh some of them include
you know the google open image data set
and also the lisa traffic data set and
there is also a german traffic sign
recognition benchmark data set
we kind of collected our own data set
apart from that we also use the
available data set
that is existing already and here are
some sample
images from our custom data set as you
can see this was collected by walking
in the sidewalk areas in monrovia's
cities and
the curb that i said was specifically
collected to detect the elevation
changes
that is when the uh there is a
transition from
getting going from a sidewalk to the
road or from road to the sidewalk
for curb detection apart from color
images we also used
the depth images because the depth image
also you know
extracts the uh depth information
from the uh depth image
so so like i mentioned earlier advanced
perception is pretty
involved we also utilized
some pre-trained models and uh some of
the splitting models are
oakdis you know depth leptia is object
recognition model
that comes along with them this model is
trained on pascal uoc
i think it has 13 classes and we also
use
a lot of self-driving car models we kind
of treated this problem as
a subset of self-driving
problem and we utilized uh open wino's
road segmentation models
and we also used uh you know tested with
semantic segmentation models we also
explored some cityscape models
that was uh trained in tensorflow
so apart from this we also trained our
own models on custom data set
to detect all those classes that was
discussed earlier such as
traffic lights road signs
and people and other classes
this is the overall object detection
pipeline
uh it consists of a depth image
basically sorry it consists of a color
image that is uh
feeded to the mobile net models system
overlap models one is from the depth ai
and one is from our end and some uh
since this is
an optimized model they tend to produce
a lot of false positives
the false positives was further reduced
using background
suppressor and using this
background suppression we kind of remove
these false positives
and finally produce the actual
deductions
so here are some sample detections uh
i'm not sure if this is clear
uh you can see the traffic lights being
detected
and uh some uh yellow payments which is
mainly meant for
the visually impaired people this is
usually
put around the interest intersection
areas and here is an example where the
system
can detect stop sign and also detect
fire hydrant
and the system can also detect public
trash cans and also
you know sign board sometimes so this is
the output of
object detection models apart from this
the system can also detect the road
pixels and road markings
here is a sample output the image on the
left
is showing the detections of people
including bicycle along with person
it can also detect the car it can also
detect the traffic light
the image on the right column is showing
what pixel is what like for example on
the road
all the road pixels are showing red and
the road markings are
shown with blue color and the green
markings show
the curves that is the transitioning
from the sidewalk to the
road side
and we are also able to perform
crosswalk detection
mainly by using the same model that can
detect the road markings here
and extract some features from the road
markings that is extract the road
markings and see
how long they are what is this shape
and look for any parallel line
surroundings if there is perform some
image processing and detect
crosswalks so this is overall the
advanced perception
we spoke about the primitive perception
which can detect
the presence of an obstacle and an
advanced perception can do even more it
can detect objects
and also can detect crosswalks and
understand traffic conditions
and even detect elevation changes
and this is a localizer so
it can it can the the user is localized
using uh
gps locations and here we actually added
a new a feature
where the user can save a given location
whatever the location they like be it
like if they go to a gym
regularly they can save the location of
the gym by using uh
this keyword called save location the
user can
say save location the system will
recognize those keywords
and it will ask for uh like the name to
be saved
they could save as any name so this will
be saved along with the name the gps
coordinates along with the name
and in case of if the user feels the
user is lost
they can invoke the system back using
the keyword locate
in this case the system would read back
from the saved location how close they
are to that place
like for example let's say the see the
the user is 100 meters away from
gym it will uh the system will respond
100 meters from gym
or 200 mirrors from ice cream shop and
so on so forth this will give the user
an idea of where they
are and also in case of emergencies they
can
share the gps coordinates to the
preferred contacts this is a sample
output of
being sms being sent to the preferred
contacts
the sms contact will include the
latitudes and the longitude information
the user interface involves bluetooth
earphones
and the user also the system also
contains speech recognition models
this is the user can engage with the
system by interacting
there are more features that the user
can ask for the system
one of them is describing the
surroundings the keyword here is
describe
if the user wants to know what is around
them they can ask a system
with keyword and the system will start
to respond
what the system sees like for example if
there is a car it can detect the car
and the presence of this uh car will be
translated to uh the user
using a clock notation for example if
the car is let's say
on the right hand side at 30 degrees
this will be between one o'clock or two
o'clock and this will be translated as
car 1 o'clock right and if there is
let's say a person on the left side that
will be translated as
person 11 o'clock
and this is a feature that is provided
only on
upon the request by the user and this is
extremely important
we wanted to make sure that we don't
provide too much information to the user
so that the user loses focus which is
one of the very common
drawbacks in the existing apps a lot of
apps do a lot of things and they provide
a lot of information to the user
but after using it for five minutes the
user cannot use it because it's so much
information to the user we wanted to
reduce that
so we wanted to provide only the
critical updates to the user
the the updates from the primitive
perception that is showing if an
obstacle is present or not is considered
critical
that is the default update that is
provided and everything else
is provided upon the request from the
user like for example this describe
would be provided
only by request by the user it won't be
provided automatically
and finally we have a demo video
sometimes when i play this demo video in
zoom it doesn't show up
uh uh let me see like how this one turns
out here
yellow pavement 10 o'clock person 11
o'clock traffic lights
yellow paved one o'clock traffic light
two
o'clock yellow pavement
one traffic light eleven o'clock
i'm not sure if you're able to hear the
voice
yeah okay oh nice okay i'm glad
so so basically uh what the system is
doing is
this is a feature that is described
which is provided by the user request
the system will start to uh
you know start to convey what the system
is seeing in clock notation if there's a
person it'll say person
one o'clock car two o'clock traffic
light three o'clock and so on and so
forth
and at the same time you can see uh
there are three
uh images being displayed here the first
image is the object detection
the objects that are being you know
detected and the middle image
is the semantic segmentation that is the
road markings that is being
detected and the curb edges that is
being detected
and also the road pixels the image at
the bottom is the primitive perception
where the presence of points is detected
and all this is running in real time in
our system
uh yeah that's mostly the
uh most part of what our system can do
um i hope like you know this system our
solution will be taken by
others and now it continues to grow our
solution is open source
and we have a team of volunteers uh
people who are uh uh
visually impaired also contributing and
joining our team
and it's uh we have a fixed set of
milestones to achieve in the coming few
months
we recently launched a gofundme campaign
to raise
money for this the idea is to make this
solution free
and anyone should be able to use uh you
know buy their hardware on their own
and download our code and put together
and start to put it in use
and our team is currently focused on you
know making this
uh making a positive impact in the
visually impaired people community
and also provide them more freedom
and allowing them to do the things they
want to do
and also increase their activities
and involvement in the daily activities
uh yeah i think i might be
i'll pass the allocated time
there are some limitations a lot of
limitations with their solutions
i'll take a minute maybe to finish this
off the models might one of the
drawbacks is
we are using deep learning models it
might not generalize
uh to other cities this is something
that we want to test it
and uh adding more models feature would
be
a bottleneck and like i mentioned
earlier the audio interface might block
the audio queue from the user which is
one of the
biggest uh cues they rely on
we already have a solution for that we
are looking at haptic gloves one of our
team members have developed a haptic
class
to convey the presence of obstacles and
other informations
um it's a wireless clause and
we still will be going with the uh you
know earphones but we'll be using a bone
conduction earphones
so the ears will be still exposed but
the
the audio will be provided via the bone
conduction mechanism
and we need of course we need power
maintenance mechanism
and we will need two sensors to cover
the entire coverages
on the top and the bottom and
and human eyes have a larger field of
view
compared to the camera view this is
something that we have to address
there are a few more limitations as well
i thought like these are some
major ones to uh note
and uh thanks again for having me here
pleasure to be here
uh if you have any questions i'm happy
to answer them
thanks a lot for being with us it's very
inspiring
now it's the challenging moment that i
want to say your name right and we are
just going to do a cross check and if i
say it wrong you correct me again jack
dish
yep so thank you so much once again for
uh being with us anyone has any
questions
let us just check for a moment i have a
question in the meanwhile
uh when you mention regarding power
maintenance uh how much autonomy
the would someone have with this system
today
in even autonomy yeah uh
so they have so we are currently in the
process of getting tested by actual
visually impaired people one of our
teammates
so so far i have to see the system uh
it can work uh pretty much on its own
it can detect a lot of things and it can
provide the feedback based on the voice
it is it is kind of uh at least i would
say
the important uh features that is
expected of this problem like you know
detecting where the obstacle
is and also detecting where the things
are it's it's pretty autonomous
by by itself uh however like you know a
good
just in case would this be when the
system is tested by the actual visually
impaired people
right i would say you know using uh deep
learning methods and also point load
methods we are able to achieve
a good amount of uh autonomy
thanks yes sir there's a question from
youtube
someone is wondering where they can
where they can find the code so if you
could share a link
to a github potentially or something
like that oh yes
um
i don't have the link and here but uh
let me find the paper
you can put it to the meetup that's
probably the best way where people can
find it back
in the meetup page okay would i be able
to do that
yes okay yeah if you want you can share
here on the chat and then we can uh
paste that there is no problem yeah let
me quickly uh
share it here i'm looking for a paper it
was published
this year in the workshop in cvpr
the paper has the link
so meanwhile if you have if there is any
other question
uh um i have a quick question
uh first of all great work um
from your point of view i mean now you
build a system that
faces many challenges because it's so
demanding this task
to do it let alone have it in a portable
and user-friendly way
so if you were to let's say outsource
the
challenges to the environment and then
try to find kind of a
smart city urban planning for these
disabled people
who help such systems you have any
concrete suggestions of what would help
systems like the ones you build
but you know to design a city or streets
or pavements and so on
yeah so yeah that's a great question so
so this is just the initial prototype
the idea is you know we want to
have developers and any kind of people
who want to
make this project grow right so right
now this is a prototype that can
show people that you know we can solve
this visualization system problem using
the existing deep learning methods and
as you move along
like you know one of the things that is
in our pipeline is
use the uh you know slam the mapping
algorithms
to locate them even more precise rather
than using gps
like this kind of aligns with your you
know street mapping and things like that
right right
and as we continue to do this this will
also start to
you know add more complexities in the
hardware and cost
so you need to achieve some kind of
balance between like how much features
you had
depending on the computing power and the
hardware that is required
and one of the models would be like you
know maybe
if the user is just interested in you
know knowing where the obstacles are
or maybe uh you know detecting where
things are
right it's a this is a lighter version
they don't have to buy
a heavier uh expensive or expensive or a
heavier solution for that matter they
can
they can use a simpler version so the
idea is to have
kind of tiers of solutions and depending
on what the user is expecting
they can you know download the code and
purchase the required hardware but
however
the important thing is we need developer
to come
forward and start to contribute to this
we have some people in our team already
were working on this
uh we have people who are looking into
mapping using slam
for localization and we have
a haptic loss that is uh developed which
you want to
uh you know productize and there are
some efforts along this line
this lines
thanks i send the uh
pick it up link
where sorry
i'm sorry what was that where did you
post the link
in the chat
you don't see it
okay let me send it to everyone i don't
know why the default is set to alex
okay yep uh can you see the uh thing now
yeah if anyone was interested here we're
happy to have you with us
and feel free to reach out to me
or any of our team members we are you
know happy to
educate you and if you're interested we
can also contribute to the project
okay thank you so much uh jack dish for
being with us
uh for uh everyone that is here with us
uh thank you so much uh for
being part of these meetups thanks to
luciano thanks to
jagdish for the inspiring presentations
we have now a little bit of networking
if you are
willing to do it at wonder so i think
theodore is going to post the details on
the chat
uh thank you so much for being with us
theodore would you like to
say something as well yes so yeah thank
you
thank you again uh thank you for the two
presentation was
great meetup uh i will basically share
the link
in uh in the chat
and also i will share it in the meetups
so
if you are on youtube and you want to
join
please just go to meetup look for pi
data meetup
uh berlin or hamburg and it should be
the event of today and in the
comments you will find a link to the
wonder
great so with that i will stop the live
on youtube and the recording and
i will invite you everyone to want to go
to wonder or
have a nice evening bye
thank you and thank you thanks